today's speed round is brought to you by
verizon all right chris let's get right
to it let's start with the nfc east a
variety of trades made
which nfce trade did you like the best
i i think the one you know i i like i
talked about i like the cowboys one a
lot i like devonte smith but
the giants one is the one i think that
jumps out to me more than any
i mean one i think they got a really
damn good football player in kadarius
tony
i mean he's a weapon you know like a
jalen waddle he's tyreek hill-ish in a
lot of weight
so man with the firepower they already
have but then
really to get a first-round pick in next
year's draft
and then that that's just it was a
phenomenal play there by
by gettleman and the giants and like you
like we talked about earlier it's
the eagles are rebuilding i don't expect
them to have a
awesome you know football team so i
don't know what the giants fans are
going for who'd they want
this guy's got three rockets up his butt
and can break tackles and break ankles
and do it all he's gonna be really good
for their football team
and think about it instead of
overreacting when they get leapfrogged
for devonta smith and taking tony there
they make the strategic decision and
dave gettleman the gm of the team
finally proving he is capable of trading
down they go down nine spots they pick
up that first rounder next year
and they get cadarius tony presumably
the guy they would have taken
at 11 if they had put a name on the card
then because
it was widely believed they were going
receiver and that's why the eagles
cut the line in front of them to get
devonta smith so it worked out well
for the new york giants i agree with you
that was the best nfc east trade of the
night because they still got their guy
and they got a first rounder next year
when it'll be easier to scout these guys
because there will be
private workouts and visits to teams and
a scouting combine most likely next year
all right which alabama first rounder
can make the biggest immediate impact
and there were six of them last night
that's unreal it's unreal go ahead you
go first i don't know you know you who's
who's the one that jumps out to you
i think it's not jay harris he's gonna
have the ball the most he's the last of
this
of the guys taken uh and he uh
at the steelers at number 24 he's going
to have the football in his hands
and as i've said many times you don't
use a first round
pick on a running back in today's game
unless you are ready
to ride him hard and i think they're
going to do it
in ben roethlisberger's likely final
season hey who knows
maybe najee harris can do so much this
year that roethlisberger can squeeze one
more year out of his body chris
you're right who knows if they can run
the ball protect play brady ball like
they did in tampa
i don't doubt that because i mean big
ben's arm is still good
now that's not going to be like a
concern you're not going to be like oh
man he can't make the throws anymore
he's still gonna be capable of doing all
that so uh
yeah it's i mean these damn alabama guys
this damn alabama football team it's
unbelievable i mean it's
every year it's just stud after stud
after stud after stud
they all got pressure on them there's no
doubt about it you know i'm between two
guys
because patrick certain of course in the
afc west uh yeah reinforcements needed
we have to play patrick mahomes and
justin herbert four times a year
we need some people that can cover but i
think i'm going to go with jalen waddle
i'm going to go with jaylen waddles to
be the guy that's the biggest immediate
impact
you know just because he's such a need
for their football team
he's going to fit the role within that
new england system and the passing game
a little bit to do the julian edelman
stuff and all that
but yet they're going to have a more an
explosive element role for him too
and of course tua needs it their offense
needs it
everything there so i think i'm going to
go with jalen waddle there i really
like that pick do you think that they
went to tua and said which of the two
alabama i know should we take should we
take jalen should we take devontae
i would think so i would think there was
at least a conversation about hey tell
us about both of these guys and
you know what's your scouting report at
the very least
hey it's this is i mean you could talk
to teams that would just go whoa i mean
jamar chase is unbelievable
right i mean devonte smith i know i know
a handful of teams that had him as the
number one receiver on the board
and then of course jalen waddle was this
guy that i never heard was like
everybody's
number one guy on the board but
everybody was like man he can make some
big plays and he's explosive and
everything like that so
that's where it surprised me a little
bit um but damn
he's a good football player and he's
going to make their offense a whole lot
more explosive
hey i had heard that if it was down to
jaylen waddle and jamar
chase for the dolphins they were going
water was their guy
to make that choice they didn't get a
chance to make that choice because chase
was off the board by the way
devonta smith told us earlier this week
he wants to wear number six
khalil tate has number six for
the uh philadelphia eagles so it looks
like there's gonna have to be some sort
of a transaction that happens to get
devante smith in number six with the
philadelphia eagles
okay um which quarterback should be
happiest with his new protector
which tackle your skipping was going to
be the best which one did i skip
well you got to read well you know what
and look at what we're capable but you
know what we're capable of doing
we're capable of pretending that didn't
happen and then i can circle back
afterwards right
it's more seamless that way oh right all
right right so we're sticking with the
one that i did
which quarterback should be happiest
with his new protector right yeah we're
capable of going in order too just to
let you know we're capable both ways
there buddy i didn't know you read the
sheets
you just told me an hour ago you don't
read them i didn't not last night at 12
15.
i didn't know you could read texas boy
yeah i barely can that's about all they
taught me there was how to read that's
it
uh qb should be the happiest i
you know it i i think it's cr i think
you got to go with kirk cousins here i
mean of course
hey we could throw in jared goff into
that conversation to have penny sewell's
really amazing too
but i just think from the minnesota
angle it was such a necessity for their
football team
like we kind of talked about i mean you
know cousins to your point is not the
most mobile guy in the world but the
whole team
and the way they play is set up through
their run game and their bootleg
and if they can't really be successful
in that type of stuff
then it's going to be an uphill battle
dara saw arguably the best pass
protecting left tackle in the draft too
so i really like that pick from the
vikings there
it was either elijah veritacker or
christian darussal for the vikings at
14. so they were
able to kind of do what the giants did
they go down nine spots they pick up two
third round picks now they gave up a
fourth round pick also
this is a team that needs edge rushers
and i won't be surprised
if they don't use both of those picks in
round three on edge rushers or at least
between the second round and the third
round
two picks on edge rushers they need to
develop some guys to help that side of
the ball
but look kirk cousins
needs to be able to run the play that's
called when the walls close in
it's over so they needed that
infrastructure
on the offensive line and uh it made
sense for them
if they had a very close match between
vera tucker and darasaw to get a couple
of third round picks and still get one
of the two guys
that worked out for the right way i
think kirk cousins should be happy and
he also should be happy that
justin fields didn't fall to 14 because
there was a chance the vikings wouldn't
take
man would have made for a much different
narrative uh today than
what we otherwise would be addressing
all right now i will
go back to the one that i inadvertently
skipped over
thank you very much for pointing that
out to the world christopher which first
round quarterback situation not
quarterback cornerback situation
are you the most excited about there
were five
corners taken in all last night well you
know the one
i'm most excited about we hit on it
already more than my modern medical
miracle
uh i mean caleb thorley to the tennessee
titans
uh is the one i'm most excited about
because i mean to me
it could be like a randy moss type story
where oh he fell to here and now he's
one of the best you know in the league
at his position that type of stuff
farley has that type of talent and the
way they play
you know they want island corners they
want stephon gilmours in the thai laws
of the world
that can get and just go hey i got you
that's it the rest of the defense has
got their own game plan but i got you
and that's where caleb farley will will
thrive
and i like that you made the randy moss
point because it was the tennessee
titans who took the last receiver
before randy moss in 1998 trivia do you
remember who it was ooh
1998. hold on is is it
was derek mason that high of a pick no
think music city miracle oh ooh
well okay i'm thinking of the tie oh
that's um
oh i know damn that's i know he's now a
high school princess i know what's his
name i'm not gonna be able to kevin
dyson dyson nope number 87
damn okay yeah good one good one there
met tripp down memory and uh
and caleb farley one pick after the
randy mossbot of 21. i i agree with you
there i am excited about that i also
though want to see
if jc horn is as good as the panthers
believe right because remember when they
traded for sam darnold
they they said hey we now can take the
best available player and as mack jones
fell to eight
remember there was that noise maybe they
would trade up yeah to try to get mac
jones
mac jones is there they didn't flinch
they didn't blink they didn't take him
or justin fields at number eight they
went with the best player on the board
and for them it was jc horn and we'll
see if he's as good as advertised he's
definitely got the confidence yes
and you better have a lot of confidence
if you're going to thrive as a corner in
today's nfl
they're all about like size and length
there with carolina we've heard matt
rule say that and jc horn fits that mold
he does yeah he wasn't my favorite
corner in the draft but
when you talk about physicality you know
the ability to kind of jam receivers and
beat them up at the line of scrimmage
and not do all that stuff
that's where he's really good and of
course he's a good tackler to go on top
of that
so they got a really good football
player yeah for my money i think it's an
over drafting a little number eight
but yeah i'm with you that's gonna be
one to watch for for sure
i'm sure they were trying to trade down
to a degree i mean that's that was the
rumor around the carolina panthers but i
guess they didn't find the suitor and
they got jc horn uh part of the problem
was
they weren't going to get jc horn if
they traded down because that's who the
eagles were targeting
when they were initially trying to trade
up once horn was off the board it
pivoted i believe to devonta
away from jc horn all right let's take a
break
big kahuna draft as it relates to the
first night of the 2021 draft when pft
live continues right after this
pro football talk is brought to you by
verizon
built right for business
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports